matt ryan will play this year at age 36
and matt ryan obviously has been an
atlanta falcon since 2008. i was there
on the night of the draft and
and you still had people uh walking
around atlanta and michael vick jerseys
and saying in essence that matt ryan
will never be accepted here
well
you know in the last 13 years
matt ryan has started all but three
games for the atlanta falcons and so
i look at matt ryan and i just say
you know
it's one thing
if matt ryan had been showing
signs of significant decline
okay but he but he hasn't
and so my question is
if i am the atlanta falcons
you know i i wonder why everyone on the
outside world is giving us a quarterback
because this quarterback who says he
wants to play into his 40s
i mean
you've got the position solved for the
next four or five years now
it could be could be
that they don't want to pay matt ryan 40
million or whatever he's got a huge
contract as you know and maybe they
don't want to pay him that but
the fact is
you know if the cap starting in 2023
starts to go up in 2024 and 25 it goes
up that's going to be a manageable
salary to be able to handle and so i
guess what i'm saying mike is if i'm the
atlanta falcons i'm either trading that
pick or i'm not taking a quarterback
yeah matt ryan signed for two more years
beyond 2021 with some huge cap numbers
but you know you think back to 2008
thomas dimitrov just getting started as
gm mike smith getting started as head
coach in that 13 years until this year
when it bottomed out and arthur blank
decided to change out both jobs you had
dimitrov consistently the gm two coaches
in that stretch when
many of the teams have been through
three or four or more having that
quarterback and having that stability
is what cements you over the long haul
and that may be why they're thinking
about it that's why we're hearing these
reports of arthur smith wanting to stick
with matt ryan terry fontenot wanted to
go with the quarterback because if you
unlock that young franchise quarterback
you're laying the foundation for a
decade or longer of consistent
contention not necessarily super bowls
but good enough that there's not going
to be a house cleaning that all you have
to do is put the team around him and
that that's not easy to do but it's a
lot easier than finding the franchise
quarterback and i just think these
opportunities to get a franchise
quarterback are so few and far between
peter that you got to take them when
they come and the one thing that i think
a lot of people have lost sight of as it
relates to what the falcons will do what
they're going to do is whatever arthur
blank wants them to do at the end of the
day he'll make it known what his
preference is most likely via rich mckay
who will make it known to terry fontenot
and arthur smith what the guy who owns
the team wants with that very high
profile pick and that's what they'll do
i agree mike but i i also think that
when when thomas de mitroff was there
he obviously had to answer to arthur
blank
but
it was thomas de mitroff's idea to go up
for julio jones for that passle of draft
choices uh in 2000 whatever 10 or 11.
and and
although clearly arthur blank has to
sign off on these things
i wouldn't be shocked if arthur blank is
sidling up to you know his new general
manager
uh terry fontenot and basically saying
hey listen you know make sure you think
about the quarterback make sure you
think about
you know
we're not going to be in position to get
one of these guys again and all that
stuff
but i doubt sincerely
that arthur blank is telling terry
fontenot we're taking a quarterback i
doubt he's telling arthur smith we're
taking a quarterback i i just don't
think he operates his team that way now
i'm sure he's not going to be shy with
his opinion he never is
but
i do think
uh that this is going to be a decision
that at the end of the day is going to
be made by the general manager and the
coach
but as you say mike
if if if arthur blank
totally disapproves of it
there could be a significant discussion
to be had
one of the things i always say the
beauty of being a billionaire you never
have to come out and say what you'll
want
you just make your opinion known and
and smart people who work for you will
understand what's what that what that
means and what they should do if they
were hey you know what mike mike i'm
glad ozzie newsome didn't do that in 19
i'm glad ozzie newsome didn't do that in
1996
because remember in 1996 the ravens are
new to baltimore
and uh
and and so obviously you've got ozzie
newsome running his first draft ever
and art model the owner of the team says
hey i really want lawrence phillips we
need to fill up our stadium we need we
need offense we need offense here i want
lawrence phillips
and and uh
hey look at the end of the day
you know ozzy newsome wasn't positive
that this might not at some point cost
him his job but ozzie newsome said no
we're taking jonathan ogden and then
with our second pick in the first round
we're not moving up to go get a big
offensive weapon with our second pick if
he's there we're taking ray lewis
so
i mean obviously it's one of the best
draft rounds maybe it's not quite gale
sayers and dick butkus for the bears in
the 60s in the same first round but that
is one heck of a first round and so i i
really think that
if arthur blank hired
terry fontenot and if he hired arthur
smith
he hired him because he has faith in
them to take the atlanta falcons to a
super bowl
in my opinion i don't think
the first big
matter of business for the organization
he's going to say hey guys stand back
we're taking whoever it is justin fields
trey lance mac jones
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports